buenos días de hecho no sé qué hora son
para ti pero para mí es de mañana
bienvenidos a la presentación sobre
pendiente y ordenada al origen de una
recta en esta presentación no te voy a
enseñar cómo calcular la pendiente y la
ordenada pero espero que despierte tu
intuición acerca de lo que representa la
pendiente y la ordenada al origen en una
recta para esto voy a hacer algo
distinto a lo que normalmente hago vamos
a trabajar con el ejercicio para
graficar rectas que se encuentra en el
sitio web de khan academy y espero que
con lo que hagamos darte la intuición de
lo que representa la pendiente y el
orden al origen en la recta cuando
arranca la aplicación ésta empieza con
la ecuación de la recta que igual a 1 x
1 que es la misma que igual a x1 vemos
que para esta recta la pendiente es
igual a 1 si revisas el vídeo de
introducción a la gráfica ción ahí
explicamos por qué la pendiente es el
coeficiente de la equis y aquí puedes
ver que para cada avance de x en uno el
avance también es en uno también podías
concebir que la pendiente es elevación
sobre avance cada que hay una elevación
en una unidad hay un avance en una
unidad elevación significa cuánto
mientras que avance significa cuando
cambia para x en este caso elevación
sobre avance es igual a 1 y la ordenada
el origen es donde la recta intersecta
el eje a medida que vayamos cambiando la
pendiente y la orden al origen para esta
recta yo espero que todo esto te quede
más claro veamos qué pasa cuando cambia
la pendiente de uno a tres medios tres
medios es 1.5 tenemos una recta que es
mucho más inclinada que la anterior
seguimos cambiando si la pendiente es 2
la recta sigue aumentando su inclinación
seguimos avanzando 5 medios es 2.5
seguimos avanzando ahora es una
pendiente de 3 y así podemos ver como la
inclinación de la recta va aumentando
regresemos podemos ver entonces cómo la
recta va perdiendo inclinación de hecho
la meta de este podríamos decir juego es
hacer que la recta pase por esos dos
puntos azules que se presentan ahí a ver
vamos a regresar este caso es
interesante qué pasa con la recta igual
a 0 x 1 en este caso como 0 x x 0 la
ecuación es igual a 1 y hace sentido una
pendiente de 0 quiere decir que no hay
cambio en y no importa el valor de xl
lleva a ser siempre igual a uno por lo
cual la ecuación de la recta es igual a
uno demostrado que es lo que pasa con la
pendiente no está ahora como de
izquierda a derecha la recta va bajando
la pendiente ya es negativa es menos un
medio indicando que la recta baja aquí
vemos que cuando la elevación es menos 1
el avance es 2 es por eso que la
pendiente es menos 1 sobre 2 y creo que
aquí es la idea que mientras el valor de
la pendiente va aumentando la recta
tiene una mayor inclinación o una mayor
pendiente aunque no me gusta usar lo que
estamos definiendo en la definición pero
eso lo has podido ver en las gráficas
ahora veamos qué pasa con la ordenada al
origen esto se pone cada vez más
interesante qué pasa entonces con la
ordenada al origen caray como me pasó
eso es extraño bueno regresemos qué pasa
con la ordenada el origen no está ahora
la pendiente es menos 1 la recta va
bajando pero la intercepción con el eje
y es en 2 si aumentamos la ordenada el
origen en 1 entonces la intersección con
el eje que va a ser en 3 veamos
no aquí no aquí solo incremento en un
medio aquí lo tenemos la orden al origen
ya es 3 hagamos otro ejercicio
aquí lo tenemos es de hecho es la misma
recta lo único que cambió fue la
ubicación de los dos puntos de hecho
hagamos eso encontremos la ecuación de
la recta que pasa por estos dos puntos
veamos
yo creo que tenemos que disminuir la
ordenada al origen vamos disminuyendo
nuevamente no sabía que eso pasaba vamos
bajando la orden al origen estamos
desplazando hacia abajo la recta
seguimos disminuyendo es ordenada el
origen me parece ahora que necesitamos
incrementar la pendiente vamos a
incrementar el valor de la pendiente lo
subimos creo que ya tenemos la pendiente
adecuada parecer que es la misma
pendiente de la recta que pasa por esos
puntos entonces vamos a disminuir aún
más la ordenada al origen vamos bajando
el valor de la orden al origen de tal
manera que ajuste a los puntos
creo que ahí está lo hemos logrado es
una recta con pendiente siete cuartos es
1.75 es mayor que la original de
pendiente 1 y de hecho lo podíamos
calcular pero lo que quiere es que
tengas la intuición de la pendiente y la
ordenada al origen y la intersección con
el eje y la orden al origen para esta
recta aquí la tenemos es menos 13
cuartos la podemos ver ligeramente abajo
de menos 3 hagamos otro ejercicio y si
quieres puedes entrar a este módulo y
jugar tal y como lo estamos haciendo
aquí veamos ahora queremos que la recta
pase por estos dos puntos
parece que la pendiente de la recta que
tenemos es mayor tenemos que disminuir
la a está parece que está si es siete
octavos lo cual significa que por cada
avance de 8 tenemos una elevación de 7 y
eso lo vamos a poder dibujar en otro
módulo que voy a desarrollar aquí lo
estoy haciendo un poco al vuelo pero lo
hace en otro módulo de hecho cada módulo
que hago lo hago el vuelo una disculpa
por eso aunque bueno tú no estás pagando
por eso así es que no me deberíais
me parece que estoy muy distraído no
vamos entonces la recta hacia arriba lo
estamos haciendo incrementando la
ordenada al origen observa que no cambia
la inclinación de la recta le estamos
desplazando hacia arriba no estamos
modificando la pendiente de la recta
estamos modificando la ordenada al
origen y ahí lo tenemos la ecuación de
la recta es siete octavos de x más 13
cuartos veamos que cumple lo que hemos
dicho en la pendiente si avanzamos en 8
debemos de elevarnos en 7
veamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
avanzamos 8 horizontalmente y ahora
vamos a elevar 7 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 de hecho llegamos al punto
exactamente y estamos de nueva cuenta
sobre la recta o desarrollar algo para
ti de tal manera que si te confundes no
te decepciones hagamos uno más aquí lo
tenemos ok
aquí lo tenemos dónde está el otro punto
veamos si está hacia la derecha donde
está el otro punto hay muchos errores
tengo que corregir los errores de estos
programas aquí y aquí lo tenemos aquí
tenemos el punto ya apareció tenemos que
encontrar la recta que pasa por esos dos
puntos
parece que la pendiente es negativa no
está negativa una pendiente negativa
fraccionaria y la ordenada el origen
estaría por acá 7 y un poquito más 7
fracción empecemos disminuyendo la
pendiente se me hace que volver a
brincar aquí tenemos ya igual a 0 x 1
implementemos la pendiente esto se está
comportando muy raro esta aplicación no
la había visto hace mucho tiempo y por
lo visto la desarrollé cuando mis
habilidades de programador eran más bien
limitadas bien esa pendiente
parece que es la adecuada movamos la
recta hacia arriba
vamos a subir la línea
estoy ayudando con la pendiente no vamos
a ver vamos a acercarnos vamos a
acercarnos a ver si es la pendiente
adecuada está lo hemos logrado y
obtuvimos la ecuación de la recta y
teníamos razón la pendiente es negativa
podemos ver que la recta va bajando pero
no lo hace tan abruptamente la pendiente
es de menos un tercio y esto lo podemos
ver en nuestra gráfica cuando avanzamos
3 1 2 3 la elevación disminuye 1 la
elevación disminuye 1 ahí estamos es por
eso que la pendiente es menos un tercio
y la ordenada al origen es 22 tercios
esto es 7 enteros un tercio aquí tenemos
la orden al origen la recta intersecta
el eje y en un tercio el camino entre 7
y 8 yo creo que esto te ha brindado algo
sobre la intuición de lo que representa
la pendiente y la ordenada el origen en
una recta lo que podemos hacer es que tú
puedas entrar directamente este módulo
para que puedas por ti mismo jugar con
las rectas como lo hemos hecho voy a
desarrollar otros módulos donde puedas
calcular directamente la pendiente y la
ordenada al origen de las rectas de tal
manera que sigas ampliando tu intuición
sobre esto espero
y divertido lo que hemos estado haciendo
a mí esto me entusiasmó mucho cuando lo
hice por primera vez es bastante visual
pasarla bien